Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Concern and care for others' feelings are virtues we seek to instill in our children, yet they are sorely lacking in many adult Americans today. Flip on the news, scroll through social media sites, or read the comments on any news article, and you realize just how unempathetic so many of us are. There's scientific research to back up the notion that Americans are caring less and less for others. For instance, one study found a steep decline in empathy among young people from 1979 to 2009. One of the authors of that study is joining me today. Dr. Sarah Conrath is an associate professor of philanthropic studies at Indiana University
您好，欢迎收听美国心理学会推出的双周播客《心理学谈话》，本节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。对他人的感受给予关心和爱护是我们希望在孩子身上培养的美德，然而，如今许多美国成年人却严重缺乏这种品质。打开新闻，浏览社交媒体，或者阅读任何新闻文章下的评论，你就会意识到我们中有多少人是多么缺乏同理心。有科学研究支持美国人对他人的关心越来越少的观点。例如，一项研究发现，从1979年到2009年，年轻人的同理心水平急剧下降。该研究的作者之一今天来到了我们的节目。莎拉·康拉斯博士是印第安纳大学慈善研究系的副教授，
and director of the interdisciplinary program on empathy and altruism research. She teaches classes on the psychology of giving and altruism and health. Her other work has also found that narcissism is on the rise in young people, and she's done some fascinating research examining narcissism's effect on social media usage. We'll be exploring why empathy is declining and what we can do to create more kindness and caring in our communities. Welcome, Dr. Conrath. Thanks for having me. When I was researching this topic, I came across an article in the New York Times from 1989, the cited research that found that newborn babies can display empathy, which was notably by crying in response to another nearby baby. Other research from our journal developmental psychology from that same time period found that mothers have a profound influence on their child's development of empathy.
同时也是同理心与利他主义研究跨学科项目的主任。她教授关于给予的心理学以及利他主义与健康的课程。她的其他研究还发现，年轻人的自恋倾向正在上升，她还进行了一些引人入胜的研究，探讨自恋对社交媒体使用的影响。我们将探讨同理心为何下降，以及我们能做些什么来在社区中创造更多的善意和关怀。欢迎您，康拉斯博士。谢谢邀请。在研究这个话题时，我偶然发现《纽约时报》1989年的一篇文章，文中引用的研究发现，新生儿能够表现出同理心，具体表现为对附近另一个婴儿的哭声做出哭泣反应。来自我们《发展心理学》期刊同一时期的其他研究发现，母亲对孩子同理心的发展有着深远的影响。
From your perspective, is it nature, is it nurture, or is it both? And why are mothers more influential in the development of empathy? Based on research that I know of, it's actually both, like most things in psychology. There's lots of research showing that empathy has a genetic component, about half of empathy that a baby is born with is a different. genetic component. But then the parenting, the schools, the community, the environment, the culture can have an influence on empathy as well. So the context matters along with the genetics. And I like that study actually on the prying response because even primates, other primates, have that kind of response and that what I call proto-empathy. It's the building block of
从您的角度来看，这是天性使然、后天培养，还是两者兼有？为什么母亲在同理心发展中更具影响力？根据我所了解的研究，这实际上两者兼有，就像心理学中的大多数事物一样。有大量研究表明同理心具有遗传成分，婴儿出生时所具备的同理心约有一半来自遗传。但随后，教养、学校、社区、环境和文化也会对同理心产生影响。因此，除了遗传因素外，环境也很重要。我实际上很喜欢那个关于哭泣反应的研究，因为即使是灵长类动物，其他灵长类动物，也有那种反应，我称之为“原始同理心”。它是构建
empathy to feel what others are feeling, that emotional contagion, but obviously we need to go a lot more further for it to be deeper, more mature empathy. So other animals, animals other than humans, you're saying, do exhibit empathy? Different kinds of empathy, yes. Not necessarily the sophisticated kind of mental gymnastics that we can do when it comes to understanding other people's intentions and motivations. but there is some evidence by primatologists and others finding that there are some forms of empathy, including care, concern, in different types of animals, such as primates and even rats. Well, that's really fascinating thing.
同理心的基石，即感受他人的感受，那种情绪传染，但显然我们需要走得更远，才能形成更深层、更成熟的同理心。所以您是说，除了人类以外的其他动物也表现出同理心？是的，不同种类的同理心。不一定是我们在理解他人意图和动机时所能做的那种复杂的心理体操，但灵长类动物学家和其他人确实发现了一些证据，表明在不同类型的动物（如灵长类动物甚至老鼠）中存在某种形式的同理心，包括关怀和担忧。嗯，这真是太迷人了。
I mean, I could see primates, of course, because we're closely linked, but they're seeing it in rats as well. Why do you think they're seeing it in an animal that's so different from our species? I think I would guess that in many mammals, that would be what why? they would see it in animals that are that rear their young in similar ways because of the nurturing that comes from early parenting. And that kind of links to your question about why mothers. I don't think there's something, you know, at least in humans, that makes mothers somehow better at teaching empathy, obviously, because humans are very flexible and adaptable.
我的意思是，我能理解灵长类动物，因为我们联系紧密，但他们在老鼠身上也看到了这一点。您认为为什么在与我们物种如此不同的动物身上也能看到这种现象？我想我猜在许多哺乳动物中，为什么会这样？它们之所以在以类似方式抚养后代的动物身上看到这一点，是因为早期教养带来的关怀。这与您关于为什么是母亲的问题有关。我不认为有什么东西，你知道，至少在人类中，能让母亲在教导同理心方面以某种方式更出色，显然，因为人类是非常灵活和适应性强的。
But I do think that within humans, mothers are spending a lot more time with their babies and children than fathers. And I think it's the person who's spending the time that will have the most influence on developing empathy. That would be really interesting to do this study today because the one I just mentioned we were just talking about was from 1990s. So seeing as how culture is shifted with the more stay-at-home dads, fathers may be more involved than they were at that point in time. It might be interesting to see how that would play out if, you know, fathers, if they're teaching their children more empathy. Do you think that would be the case today? It might be different. There's probably been a probably more of a role, but still, if you look at current research on the time spent with children, women are still spending more time than men, even though both women and men are spending more time over time. So since the 60s, there's been an increase in the time we actually spend with children taking care of them.
但我确实认为，在人类中，母亲花在婴儿和孩子身上的时间比父亲多得多。我认为花时间的人会对培养同理心产生最大的影响。如果今天能做这项研究会非常有趣，因为我刚才提到的我们正在讨论的那项研究是20世纪90年代的。所以，鉴于文化随着全职爸爸的增多而发生了转变，父亲可能比当时参与度更高。如果父亲能教给孩子更多的同理心，看看会如何发展，那可能会很有趣。您认为今天会是这样吗？可能会有所不同。可能确实发挥了更大的作用，但如果你看看目前关于陪伴孩子时间的研究，女性仍然比男性花费更多时间，尽管随着时间的推移，女性和男性都在花费更多时间。所以自60年代以来，我们实际花在照顾孩子身上的时间有所增加。
Really, I mean, that's probably a topic for another time, but that's really fascinating because you think today, you know, people are most people are working, you know, we're working longer hours, yet we're spending more time with their children. But you're talking about that genetic component. component, which is really fascinating. But so does that mean that some people are just inherently born more empathetic than others? I would think that they're born more responsive. So like those infants, there's probably differences in infants and which ones are more likely to cry when they hear the other one cry. And that that's a building block for later, you know, more general types of empathy that
真的，我的意思是，这可能是另一个话题，但这真的很迷人，因为你认为今天，你知道，大多数人都在工作，你知道，我们工作时间更长，但我们花在孩子身上的时间却更多了。但您谈到了那个遗传成分，这真的很迷人。但这是否意味着有些人天生就比其他人更有同理心？我想他们天生反应更灵敏。所以就像那些婴儿一样，婴儿之间可能存在差异，哪些婴儿在听到另一个婴儿哭时更有可能哭。而那是后来更普遍的同理心类型的基石，
are more mature. There are genotypes that are associated with more empathy. So people's actual genetic, you know. structures such as the oxytocin receptor gene. So there are, you know, some people who I think have more of a inherent potential, but all of us can learn. Yeah, I wanted to touch on mirror neurons, which is something that came up as I was looking into this topic. Do you think mirror neurons play a role in empathy? Mirror neurons are the areas of our brain that are overlapping with other people's actions so that if we see a person pick up a cup,
它们更成熟。有些基因型与更多的同理心相关。所以人们实际的遗传结构，比如催产素受体基因。所以，你知道，有些人我认为具有更大的内在潜力，但我们所有人都可以学习。是的，我想谈谈镜像神经元，这是我在研究这个话题时出现的一个概念。您认为镜像神经元在同理心中起作用吗？镜像神经元是我们大脑中与他人行为重叠的区域，所以如果我们看到一个人拿起一个杯子，
then the area of the brain that would light up when we pick up the cup is activated. So it shows you that there's this inherent physiological connection between people. And I do believe that mirror neurons help us to become more empathetic because they help us kind of have a moment of similar experience with somebody and that can lead to deeper expressions of empathy. Does that go along why you think empathy even exists in the first place? You talked about, you know, mother animals, nurturing their young, you know, talking about mirror neurons, it's being a pro-social behavior among animals. Is that why you think empathy exists? Is it exist to keep us, I guess, when we're pack animals, we're social animals, does it exist to keep us together? Does it exist to keep us thriving and to keep the species alive? I do think that there's a biological basis for empathy and that the reason it keeps, it stays in our societies over time is because it helps to keep infants alive, right? The nurturing, the parental nurturing helps to keep infants alive.
那么当我们拿起杯子时大脑中会亮起的区域就会被激活。所以它向你展示了人与人之间存在这种内在的生理联系。我确实相信镜像神经元有助于我们变得更有同理心，因为它们帮助我们与某人产生一种相似的体验时刻，这可以导致更深层的同理心表达。这是否符合您认为同理心最初存在的原因？您谈到了母亲动物抚养幼崽，谈到了镜像神经元，它是动物之间的一种亲社会行为。这就是您认为同理心存在的原因吗？它是为了让我们，我想，当我们是群居动物时，我们是社会性动物，它存在是为了让我们团结在一起吗？它存在是为了让我们繁荣并保持物种生存吗？我确实认为同理心有生物学基础，它之所以能随着时间的推移保留在我们的社会中，是因为它有助于让婴儿存活，对吧？这种养育，父母的养育有助于让婴儿存活。
And then we can generalize that to relatives and to people who are our friends and then even to strangers. So there obviously is a genetic component, as you mentioned. but, and it can be a learned behavior as well, the nature and nurture. How can we cultivate empathy within ourselves? There are many, many different ways and lots of research trying to increase empathy. So I don't think there's one way. I think the first thing I would say is that we have to want to. It has to be important to us.
然后我们可以将其推广到亲戚、朋友，甚至陌生人身上。所以显然有一个遗传成分，正如您提到的。但是，它也可以是一种习得的行为，即天性和教养。我们如何培养自己的同理心？有很多很多不同的方法，也有很多研究试图增加同理心。所以我认为没有唯一的方法。我想说的第一件事是，我们必须想要这样做。它必须对我们很重要。
The motivation really matters. And then from there, there's many ways. There's research showing that, for example, reading fiction actually helps to increase empathy and also focusing on similarities between yourself and others, just imagining, actually taking a moment, imagine what other people are feeling and thinking and what the world is like in their perspective. So there's many, many, many ways to increase empathy.
动机真的很重要。从那里开始，有很多方法。有研究表明，例如，阅读小说实际上有助于增加同理心，也专注于自己与他人之间的相似之处，只是想象，实际上花一点时间，想象别人在感受什么、思考什么，以及从他们的角度看世界是什么样的。所以有很多很多很多增加同理心的方法。
There's some research on the role of the arts and how it can help us to be more empathetic. And a big factor is actually just having experience, practicing with nurturing, you know, either animals or vulnerable, you know, children or babies because just the practice of interacting with another being who can't really just tell us in words what they're feeling or what they need. It helps us to tune in and to imagine and to respond. I want to touch on something you just mentioned. I found really interesting was about how reading fiction can make you more empathetic. Do you have more to share about why that would be the
有一些关于艺术作用的研究，以及它如何帮助我们变得更有同理心。一个重要的因素实际上只是拥有经验，练习养育，你知道，无论是动物还是脆弱的儿童或婴儿，因为仅仅是与另一个无法用语言告诉我们他们感受或需要什么的生命互动，这种练习有助于我们调频并去想象和回应。我想谈谈您刚才提到的一个让我觉得非常有趣的事情，关于阅读小说如何能让你更有同理心。您有更多关于为什么会这样的分享吗？
case because you almost think it might be nonfiction. I don't know. What is it about fiction that makes people more empathetic or increases that trait? Well, overall, the research is finding that just reading in general is helpful. But fiction in particular, because it allows us to imagine other people's lives. And oftentimes in fiction, you're getting a window into what's going on in someone's mind. So you can kind of almost like, you know, see the world through their eyes and practice what it might be like to be another person. And that person could be somebody really, really different. You know, it could be a different gender or political affiliation or ethnicity or culture. And you just have to live all these different lives and
因为你几乎认为这可能是非虚构作品。我不知道。小说有什么特质能让人更有同理心或增加这种特质？嗯，总的来说，研究发现阅读本身是有帮助的。但小说尤其如此，因为它让我们能够想象他人的生活。而且在小说中，你经常能看到别人脑子里在想什么。所以你可以几乎像，你知道，通过他们的眼睛看世界，并练习成为另一个人会是什么样子。而那个人可能是一个非常非常不同的人。你知道，可能是不同的性别、政治倾向、种族或文化。你只需要经历所有这些不同的生活，
be exposed to people you might not encounter in your everyday life from sort of the inside perspective. That is incredibly fascinating. I'm going to hold on to that one. It's a good fact to use at some point. And I want to go back to that study I mentioned in the intro here. So you found that among young people, empathy is declining. So can you share why you think empathy is on the decline? I know that was the last study ended over 10 years ago now. But from that time period, what did you find? Why do you think that was the case? And where does the research stand today in terms of what's happened between 2009 and 2019? Okay. So just to clarify, we found that college students, American college students, self-reported that they were
并从某种内在的角度接触到你在日常生活中可能不会遇到的人。这真是太迷人了。我会记住这一点。这是一个在某个时候可以使用的好事实。我想回到我在引言中提到的那项研究。所以您发现年轻人的同理心正在下降。那么您能分享一下为什么您认为同理心在下降吗？我知道那是最后一项研究，现在已经结束超过10年了。但从那个时期来看，您发现了什么？您为什么认为会这样？就2009年到2019年之间发生的事情而言，目前的研究处于什么位置？好的。所以澄清一下，我们发现大学生，美国大学生，自我报告说他们
becoming lower in empathy over time when we looked at different samples and studies using a meta-analysis over time. Other researchers also looked at national samples of high school, seniors, and college freshmen, and found similar results that there had been declines over time in concern and for others. But all these studies so far have only been done up to 2009. And we're now working on updates to these studies. So I'm not sure what's happening since then. And I know it's easy to say that assume that things are declining. But until we have the data, I don't know what's happening. But I think, you know, it's hard to say with cultural change why that's happening. So I can only guess. But after, you know, about 10 years of thinking about it at this point, I have some ideas. And
随着时间的推移，同理心水平在降低，当我们查看不同的样本和使用元分析的研究时。其他研究人员也查看了全国高中生和大学新生的样本，并发现了类似的结果，即对他人的关心随着时间的推移有所下降。但到目前为止，所有这些研究都只做到2009年。我们现在正在对这些研究进行更新。所以我不知道从那以后发生了什么。我知道很容易说，假设事情正在走下坡路。但在我们有数据之前，我不知道发生了什么。但我认为，你知道，很难说文化变革为什么会导致这种情况。所以我只能猜测。但在思考了大约10年之后，我有一些想法，并且
I'm working on a book, finishing my book called Culture of Burnout, that tries to explain what's happening and why. And over time, I started realizing that the declines in empathy were happening at the same time as the rise in mental health problems among young people. And I put together and saw those both as symptoms of burnout. And so I've been thinking about that empathy is not just, or the decline in empathy is not just an excuse down on our youth and tell them that they're not. not kind, but it's an opportunity for us to understand better the pressures that are on them
我正在写一本书，完成我的书《倦怠文化》，试图解释正在发生的事情以及原因。随着时间的推移，我开始意识到同理心的下降与年轻人心理健康问题的上升是同时发生的。我把这两者放在一起看，并将它们都视为倦怠的症状。所以我一直在思考，同理心不仅仅是，或者说同理心的下降不仅仅是对我们年轻人的指责，告诉他们他们不善良，而是一个让我们更好地理解他们所承受压力的机会
right now and the expectations that are pushing them to really just try to achieve success with a lot of, you know, challenges that earlier generations didn't face. It says incredibly high tuition rates that are rising very, very fast, higher than the cost of health care, for example. The expectations on trying to get a job with a college degree is really challenging. Rising inequality makes it very hard for average people to have a sustainable lifestyle economically and so on. So all of these different pressures on young people, I think, kind of crowd out their focus on their own self-care and care for others because they're really focused on just trying to be successful and make it. Yeah, that's a really interesting connection
现在，以及那些迫使他们真正努力去取得成功的期望，伴随着许多早期几代人没有面临的挑战。这包括极高的学费，上涨速度非常非常快，例如比医疗保健成本还要高。带着大学学位找工作的期望真的很有挑战性。日益加剧的不平等使得普通人很难在经济上拥有可持续的生活方式，等等。所以所有这些对年轻人的不同压力，我认为，挤占了他们对自己和他人的关怀，因为他们真的专注于努力成功并生存下去。是的，这是一个非常有趣的联系
that one that I hadn't even thought of. I just thought maybe it was just because, you know, what's going on in the culture and in the world today. But that's absolutely fascinating. It could be because of so much pressure on people. And of course, how can, you know, if you're already burned out yourself, you're facing all these pressures, you're worried about your economic future, which it's widely covered that, you know, generations today will not do better or maybe the same as, as previous generations. There's a lot of pressure on our young people today. And so I guess there's really no wonder why someone wouldn't be as empathetic because they're more concerned about themselves and surviving. That's what I think at this point. I think I used to think I wasn't sure
我甚至都没有想到这一点。我只是认为也许这仅仅是因为，你知道，当今文化和世界中正在发生的事情。但这绝对令人着迷。这可能是因为人们承受了太大的压力。当然，如果你自己已经精疲力竭，你面临着所有这些压力，你担心你的经济未来，这已被广泛报道，你知道，当今的一代人不会比前几代人做得更好，或者可能相同。我们的年轻人今天承受着很大的压力。所以我猜难怪有人不会那么有同理心，因为他们更关心自己和生存。这就是我目前所想的。我想我过去认为我不确定
earlier and I had other ideas, but over time, this is sort of what I see is happening. And when I've talked to young people about it, I mean, they are like, yes, like you get us. You understand this. We're very stressed out and, you know, they're just, they're really good at working, like work. and leisure. Like the, I've talked to college students about this idea of culture of burnout. And one of the things I ask about is sort of, okay, so, you know, in an ideal life, you have an eight-hour workday, which we fought for, you know, for workers' rights to have an eight-hour workday. You have eight hours of sleep and you have eight hours of leisure.
早些时候我有其他的想法，但随着时间的推移，这就是我所看到的正在发生的事情。当我与年轻人谈论它时，我的意思是，他们就像，是的，你懂我们。你理解这一点。我们压力很大，而且，你知道，他们真的很擅长工作，比如工作和休闲。就像，我曾与大学生谈论过这个“倦怠文化”的概念。我问的一件事是，好吧，所以，你知道，在理想的生活中，你有八小时的工作日，这是我们为之奋斗的，你知道，为工人的权利争取八小时工作日。你有八小时的睡眠，你有八小时的休闲。
And then, like, people start laughing. Students laugh at that. It's like, I was like, okay, I didn't know that was a joke. But okay. And, you know, just listening to stories from young people and sort of the pressures are facing and sort of how taking a break, like even just having a night off, it makes them feel really guilty. Yeah, absolutely. I wonder if that relates to a decline. Maybe people spending more time on hobbies and volunteering if you're, you know, focused on school, if you're focused on work, if you're focused on this, that or the other thing. Right. That's what I think, yes.
然后，人们就开始笑了。学生们对此感到好笑。就像，我当时想，好吧，我不知道那是个笑话。但好吧。而且，你知道，只是听听年轻人的故事，以及他们面临的压力，以及休息，比如哪怕只是休息一个晚上，都会让他们感到非常内疚。是的，绝对。我想知道这是否与下降有关。也许人们花更多时间在爱好和志愿服务上，如果你，你知道，专注于学校，如果你专注于工作，如果你专注于这个、那个或其他事情。对，这就是我所想的，是的。
Yeah, and I want to bring this over to a topic that keeps coming up in my mind today. day. The lack of empathy or the decrease in empathy that you've seen in your study, obviously we have a 10-year gap of which we don't know yet what's happened. But is that, could that be the cause of why people can be so basically nasty today? And some, you know, you read news article comments and it's just a terrible place to go. It's like where you go if you want to feel bad or I don't know. It's just sort of like you get down that rabbit hole of reading all these awful things people have to say. And, you know, I think in a lot of ways, what comes to my mind is, is the issues going on in our southern border. And just really,
是的，我想把这个话题带到一个今天一直在我脑海中浮现的话题。你在研究中看到的同理心缺乏或同理心下降，显然我们有10年的空白期，我们还不知道发生了什么。但这可能是人们今天变得如此刻薄的原因吗？而且有些，你知道，你阅读新闻文章的评论，那真是一个糟糕的地方。就像如果你想感觉不好，或者我不知道，你就会去那里。这就像你陷入了阅读人们不得不说的所有这些可怕事情的兔子洞。而且，你知道，我认为在很多方面，我脑海中浮现的是我们南部边境正在发生的问题。而且真的，
in a lot of cases, you have some people who are incredibly empathetic to the plight of people leaving oppression and violence, but you have so many people who are just downright mean about it and, you know, want to, you know, don't want to help anyone at all. Obviously, this is, there's a lot that goes into that fact into why people behave the way they do. But is this an example of people who might not feel like they have what they need so they cannot be empathetic to others? Yes, I think if people are saying cruel things to others who are oppressed or victimized or in deep trouble, that's a, that is a signal of low empathy because empathy is, we didn't even define it, but I'll define it. Empathy is both imagining other people's perspectives and their
在很多情况下，你有一些人对离开压迫和暴力的人们的困境非常有同理心，但你也有很多人对此非常刻薄，而且，你知道，根本不想帮助任何人。显然，这是，有很多因素导致人们的行为方式。但这是否是一个例子，说明那些可能觉得没有得到他们所需要的东西的人，所以他们不能对他人的同理心？是的，我认为如果人们对那些被压迫、受害或陷入困境的人说残忍的话，那是一个低同理心的信号，因为同理心是，我们甚至没有定义它，但我会定义它。同理心既是想象他人的观点和他们的
world's cognitive type of empathy. And it's also care and compassion and concern for others, that emotional empathy. So when you're not showing that for somebody, then you are showing low empathy. And I think it's hard to say whether those expressions online are a sign that, you know, empathy is really declined even more or whether people used to say those things
世界的认知型同理心。它也是对他人的关怀、同情和担忧，那种情感同理心。所以当你没有对某人表现出这一点时，那么你就是在表现出低同理心。而且我认为很难说这些在线表达是否是一个迹象，表明，你知道，同理心真的下降得更多了，还是人们过去也说那些话。
in the privacy of their home and now they just say them, you know, online. I don't know. Yeah. But it is obviously upsetting and concerning to see that groups who are in need are not getting the help that they need. Yeah, or you kept it to yourself and now you feel emboldened, perhaps, because you're,
在他们家中私下里，而现在他们只是在网上说出来，你知道的。我不知道。是的。但看到那些有需要的群体没有得到他们所需的帮助，这显然令人不安和担忧。是的，或者你以前把它藏在心里，而现在你感到胆大了，也许是因为你，
it can be anonymous online. Yeah. That could be another thing too. And this leads me to my next question about, is there, are there times in history you've noticed where even during that period of time, 1979 to 2009, where people were more empathetic, you know, an example came to mind after 9-11 where it seemed like America came together in a lot of ways, albeit briefly, perhaps. but it seemed like people came together.
它在网上可以是匿名的。是的。那也可能是另一回事。这引出了我的下一个问题，在历史上，你是否注意到即使在那段时间，即1979年到2009年之间，人们更具同理心的时期？比如9-11事件后，美国似乎在很多方面团结了起来，尽管可能很短暂。但人们似乎确实团结在了一起。
I'm not sure if that's necessarily empathy, but are there times where you've seen where people are more empathetic and times where you've seen people are less empathetic? Well, just looking at the data, it looks like it was just declining over time and especially in the accelerating since 2000. I actually looked at the graphs for my study
我不确定那是否一定是同理心，但你是否见过人们更具同理心的时期，以及人们同理心较弱的时期？嗯，仅从数据来看，它似乎随着时间的推移一直在下降，特别是在2000年之后加速下降。我实际上查看了我研究中的图表，
to see if there was a blip in 2001 and there wasn't. And as somebody who was, I had just, I'm a Canadian and I had just moved to the states in fall of 2001, so a couple weeks before 9-11. And I, as a somebody who is not a citizen living in the States at that time, I can't say that I was feeling empathy from Americans. I was feeling very nervous at the anti-immigrant sentiment. So I don't know that what Americans coming together,
看看2001年是否有波动，结果并没有。作为一个加拿大人，我在2001年秋天，也就是9-11事件前几周刚搬到美国。作为一个当时住在美国的非公民，我不能说我感受到了美国人的同理心。我感到非常紧张，因为当时有反移民情绪。所以我不知道美国人团结起来是否，
it was coming together sort of to affirm patriotism and sort of, you know, American like amazingness or something. thing, but I don't know, but empathy, I think, would have been broader and would have been empathy for other people, too, and people who were being treated badly and experiencing hate crimes because they happened to be a member of an ethnic group that, you know, that was, that was part of the 9-11 events, but obviously those individuals were not implicated. In fact, people from Middle Eastern countries, my research has found, actually score the highest in the world and empathy. Yeah, that was one thing I wanted to touch on. Are there certain people in the
这更像是为了肯定爱国主义和某种，你知道的，美国式的了不起之类的东西。但我不知道，但同理心，我认为，应该更广泛，也应该是对他人的同理心，对那些受到恶劣对待并经历仇恨犯罪的人的同理心，仅仅因为他们恰好是某个族群的成员，你知道的，那是9-11事件的一部分，但显然那些个人并没有牵涉其中。事实上，我的研究发现，来自中东国家的人在同理心方面得分实际上是全球最高的。是的，那是我想要触及的一点。世界上是否有某些人，
world who are more empathetic cultures, countries, you know, so you said Middle Eastern people, do you have specific countries on that? Yeah, so we did a study, and I'm going to, I always like to talk about the study limitations because I think people should make up their own mind about whether they think it's a, you know, something they want to believe. But we did a study. It was just kind of an accidental study where we had posted online a link to an empathy measure and people from all over the world for some reason wanted to take this measure. So we had over 104,000 people in the study from 63 different countries. But because it was just kind of an accident, the study was not intended to be a cross-cultural study. It was all in English. So that's important to keep in mind.
更具同理心的文化或国家？所以你提到了中东人，你有具体的国家数据吗？是的，我们做了一项研究，我总是喜欢谈论研究的局限性，因为我认为人们应该自己决定这是否是他们想要相信的东西。但我们确实做了一项研究。这只是一项偶然的研究，我们在网上发布了一个同理心量表的链接，出于某种原因，来自世界各地的人们都想参加这个测试。所以我们在研究中拥有来自63个不同国家的超过104,000名参与者。但因为它只是一种偶然，这项研究并不打算成为一项跨文化研究。它全部是用英语进行的。所以这一点很重要，需要记住。
But we then were able to compare the different countries and see which ones were misan empathy and lowest in empathy. And we were able to correlate empathy scores at the cultural level with behaviors like volunteering and helping and traits like individualism. So we're trying to kind of validate this as a potential measure. And currently it's like the best available study, but I still think, you know, there need to work on really understanding cultural differences in empathy. When you do a study like that, can you talk about how you measure empathy? Yeah.
但我们随后能够比较不同的国家，看看哪些国家的同理心最高，哪些最低。我们能够将文化层面的同理心得分与志愿服务和帮助行为以及个人主义等特质联系起来。所以我们试图将其验证为一种潜在的衡量标准。目前它是现有最好的研究，但我仍然认为，你知道，在真正理解同理心的文化差异方面还需要做更多工作。当你做这样的研究时，你能谈谈你是如何衡量同理心的吗？是的。
So we measure empathy using just a self-report trait measure. So the one we used and that we've used a lot is called the interpersonal reactivity index. So it's just about responding to others. And it's pretty widely used and many scientists appreciate the validity of it. And so it includes statements such as I often have tender concern feelings for those who are less fortunate. Or I try to imagine what other people's side of a disagreement, for example. And those are just off the top. of my head. Those aren't exact. But just so you get a sense of them. And then we, we correlated
所以我们使用自我报告的特质量表来衡量同理心。我们使用并经常使用的一个量表叫做人际反应指针。它只是关于对他人的反应。它被广泛使用，许多科学家认可其有效性。它包括诸如“我经常对那些不幸的人怀有温柔的关怀”之类的陈述。或者“我尝试想象争论中对方的立场”，例如。这些只是我随口想到的。它们并不完全准确。但只是为了让你有个概念。然后我们，我们将它们相关联，
them with in that cross-cultural study with rates of volunteering behaviors, which obviously, that's not empathy. That's the behavior. Empathy is either a trade or a feeling. You've talked about the countries that you found that were most empathetic. So what were countries you found that were least empathetic? But we found that individualistic countries were more likely to be low in empathy and also countries that were more accepting of emotions were higher in empathy. And we also found that higher empathy countries had higher rates of volunteering and helping strangers, but it wasn't related to charitable giving, which is interesting. And then finally, this little fun fact, and I don't remember if we actually published this,
在那个跨文化研究中，将它们与志愿服务行为的比率相关联，这显然不是同理心。那是行为。同理心要么是一种特质，要么是一种感觉。你谈到了你发现的最具同理心的国家。那么你发现哪些国家同理心最弱呢？我们发现个人主义国家更有可能同理心较低，而那些更能接受情绪的国家同理心较高。我们还发现，同理心较高的国家有更高的志愿服务和帮助陌生人的比率，但这与慈善捐赠无关，这很有趣。最后，这个有趣的小事实，我不记得我们是否真的发表过这个，
but we definitely, I definitely look because I was curious. We found that higher empathy countries had had higher temperatures on average. They were warmer. Hmm. Interesting. Because you kind of think of like a cold, cold person, cold climate. Yeah. I'm from not too far away from Kent.
但我们确实，我肯定查过，因为我很好奇。我们发现同理心较高的国家平均气温较高。它们更温暖。嗯。有趣。因为你通常会想到冷漠的人，寒冷的气候。是的。我离肯特不远，
I'm from Rochester, New York. Yay. Just across Lake Ontario. So I think I'm an empathetic person from a cold area. So that's really interesting, though, about some of the cultures, maybe the cultures where people, you find that people keep themselves don't make small talk might be different than a culture that's more like outgoing and, you know, that sort of thing. It's really, really fascinating. Yeah, there's a lot. There's a lot too there. I like, you know, I appreciate you sharing the limitations to that too, just how obviously it was only limited to, to English speakers to a certain extent. Yeah. This got me all thinking about how empathy or the lack there of might relate. to people who are more prejudiced or people who commit crimes? Are there connections between empathy and criminal behavior?
我来自纽约州罗切斯特。耶。就在安大略湖对面。所以我认为我是一个来自寒冷地区但有同理心的人。不过，关于某些文化，这真的很有趣，也许那些人们保持距离、不进行闲聊的文化，可能与那种更外向的文化不同，你知道的，就是那种情况。这真的非常非常迷人。是的，这里面有很多东西。我喜欢，你知道，我很感激你也分享了它的局限性，比如它在一定程度上仅限于英语使用者。是的。这让我开始思考同理心或其缺乏可能与那些更偏见的人或犯罪的人有何关联？同理心和犯罪行为之间有联系吗？
Are less empathetic people more likely to commit a crime? Well, I'm not sure if they're more likely to commit a crime, but research does find that on average people who are in jail for crimes, so if they've been caught, that those people score lower on empathy, both kinds of empathy, both emotional and cognitive. I don't think it means that if someone has low empathy, they're predisposed to criminal activity. I just think that, you know, people who have high empathy would find it difficult to hurt others because they're very aware of the consequences of their actions.
同理心较弱的人是否更有可能犯罪？嗯，我不确定他们是否更有可能犯罪，但研究确实发现，平均而言，那些因犯罪入狱的人，也就是如果他们被抓住了，这些人在同理心方面的得分较低，包括情感同理心和认知同理心。我不认为这意味着如果某人同理心低，他们就倾向于犯罪活动。我只是认为，你知道，具有高同理心的人会发现伤害他人很困难，因为他们非常清楚自己行为的后果。
And I think that's going to mitigate harm to others. Yeah, so earlier you defined empathy, but can you talk about the difference between cognitive and emotional empathy? we didn't touch on that. Cognitive empathy is, I see it more at this point. They've been studying this for a while. I see it more of a skill. So it's something, you know, it takes time and practice and effort and imagination.
我认为这会减轻对他人的伤害。是的，所以你之前定义了同理心，但你能谈谈认知同理心和情感同理心之间的区别吗？我们没有触及这一点。认知同理心是，我现在更多地将其视为一种技能。所以它是某种，你知道，需要时间、练习、努力和想象力的东西。
And it's when we can think about what the world is like from someone else's perspective and really from their point of view, not our own necessarily. And we can use, you know, to support that kind of imagination, we can use like our observation. So we can listen carefully, we can pay attention to body language, voice, facial expressions of emotion, and other things like that. So to me, I see that as more of a skill type process. And emotional empathy, I think it can start with that emotional contagion.
当我们能够从别人的角度思考世界是什么样子，并且真正从他们的观点出发，而不一定是我们自己的观点时，这就是认知同理心。我们可以利用，你知道，为了支持那种想象力，我们可以利用我们的观察。所以我们可以仔细倾听，我们可以注意肢体语言、声音、面部表情以及其他类似的东西。所以对我来说，我将其视为一种技能型的过程。而情感同理心，我认为它可以从那种情绪传染开始。
So just that moment of sort of feeling what the other person is feeling. But the more mature form is feeling like extending into compassion. So care, care for others. And usually the two of them go together. the research shows that people who are good at cognitive empathy tend to be also compassionate, feel more compassion for others. But you can imagine there are people out there who are good at cognitive empathy but don't care.
所以只是那种感受到对方正在感受的东西的瞬间。但更成熟的形式是感觉延伸到同情心。所以是关怀，对他人的关怀。通常两者是结合在一起的。研究表明，擅长认知同理心的人往往也富有同情心，对他人感到更多的同情。但你可以想象，有些人擅长认知同理心却并不关心他人。
And those are psychopaths and we need both together. Yeah, that's another possible another topic for our podcast psychopaths. That's very interesting topic as well. We haven't yet explored. You know, that's wrapping up our section about the study you did. and kind of bring it, bring it full circle. You're showing declining rates. You're doing a new study to see what's happened over the past 10 years.
那些就是精神变态者，我们需要两者结合。是的，那是我们播客的另一个可能的话题，精神变态者。那也是一个非常有趣的话题。我们还没有探讨过。你知道，这结束了我们关于你所做研究的部分。并将其带回原点。你展示了下降的比率。你正在进行一项新的研究，看看过去10年发生了什么。
Do you have any suggestions as a psychologist about what can be done to increase empathy? You know, if it was on the downward trajectory for those, was that 30 years? So if it was on the downward trajectory for 30 years, what can be done to make people more empathetic, to increase our cultural empathy? What do you think can be done? Well, I think I've been thinking about these, about what we can do to try to increase empathy at a broader level, not just like for individuals. Because individually, we've already talked about some things that people can do to make themselves more empathetic. But as a culture, we have to actually decide it's important, right?
作为一名心理学家，你对如何提高同理心有什么建议吗？你知道，如果它在过去，那是30年吗？如果它在30年里一直处于下降轨迹，那么可以做些什么来让人们更具同理心，来增加我们的文化同理心？你认为可以做些什么？嗯，我认为我一直在思考这些，关于我们可以做些什么来尝试在更广泛的层面上提高同理心，而不仅仅是针对个人。因为在个人层面上，我们已经讨论了一些人们可以做的事情来让自己更具同理心。但作为一个文化，我们必须真正决定它很重要，对吧？
And that means we think about, as parents thinking about prioritizing, teaching our children to care for others who are different than them. That means exposing them to people who are different, actually making an effort to, get involved in some ways. And also sometimes it might mean that we have to assess sort of what kinds of messages our children are getting from us, because oftentimes children are internalizing the need to succeed and thinking that that's the only thing that we care about for our children when, in fact, maybe parents do want their children to be caring and empathetic. But moving outside of parents, then school systems are also giving messages to children about what's important and the school is important socializing force.
这意味着我们思考，作为父母，要优先考虑教导我们的孩子去关心那些与他们不同的人。这意味着让他们接触不同的人，实际上努力去以某种方式参与其中。有时这也意味着我们必须评估我们的孩子从我们这里得到了什么样的信息，因为通常孩子们会将成功的需求内化，并认为这是我们唯一关心的事情，而事实上，也许父母确实希望他们的孩子是关心他人且有同理心的。但撇开父母不谈，学校系统也在向孩子们传达什么是重要的信息，学校是一个重要的社会化力量。
And unfortunately, there's a lot of pressure on them right now to focus on testing and sort of specific quantitative outcomes for kids. Like, if schools decide to focus more on the whole child, including social and emotional skills, that will make a huge difference. And then community interactions, I think, are important to build empathy because when we're interacting with our neighbors and we're interacting with, you know, co-workers or attending regular, either religious services or groups of various kinds that are community-based, we are interacting with people who we might not see in our tightest circles. And that can challenge us and help us to
不幸的是，他们现在面临很大的压力，要专注于考试和针对孩子的特定量化成果。如果学校决定更多地关注整个孩子，包括社交和情感技能，那将产生巨大的影响。然后我认为社区互动对于建立同理心很重要，因为当我们与邻居互动，与同事互动，或者参加定期的宗教仪式或各种基于社区的团体时，我们是在与那些我们在最紧密的圈子里可能看不到的人互动。这可以挑战我们并帮助我们，
grow and expand our circles of empathy. And in your research you did earlier, you were talking about the countries are more empathetic. Did you see a difference in the countries where it depended on what was happening in the society? If it was a country that was at war, were you seeing less rates of empathy because people were more focused on surviving? Are you seeing higher rates of empathy in countries that are doing well, that have more resources that were people, the economy is good? What are the differences did you see in that area? So we didn't look at specifically war, whether countries were at war or not, but we did look at well-being rates based on national surveys. And we did find that empathy was higher in countries
成长并扩大我们的同理心圈子。在你之前的研究中，你谈到了哪些国家更具同理心。你是否看到国家之间的差异取决于社会中正在发生的事情？如果是一个处于战争状态的国家，你是否看到同理心比率较低，因为人们更专注于生存？你在那些做得好、拥有更多资源、经济良好的国家是否看到了更高的同理心比率？你在该领域看到了什么差异？所以我们没有专门研究战争，即国家是否处于战争状态，但我们确实根据国家调查查看了幸福感比率。我们确实发现同理心在那些更幸福的国家中更高，
that were happier. You know, so it could be that happier countries, you know, lead to more empathy or that more empathy leads to more happiness or some other reason. But in any case, that link is there. And it wasn't, if I remember right, and I'd have to check, I don't think we found a connection to average income in the country. Interesting. Yeah. So my just a more on other factors. Interesting. Okay. It does seem to be linked to well-being, both. So individuals, so within individuals, empathy is associated with more happiness and well-being, but also across culture, we found the same thing. And also, you did a lot of work, you've done work on narcissism and found that rates of narcissism on young, young people are increasing. Is that related to what
你知道，所以可能是更幸福的国家导致了更多的同理心，或者更多的同理心导致了更多的幸福，或者其他原因。但无论如何，这种联系是存在的。如果我没记错的话，我需要核实一下，我不认为我们发现了与国家平均收入的联系。有趣。是的。所以我的只是更多地取决于其他因素。有趣。好的。它似乎确实与幸福感有关，两者都是。所以个人，在个人内部，同理心与更多的幸福感和福祉相关，但在跨文化中，我们也发现了同样的事情。而且，你做了很多工作，你在自恋方面做过工作，发现年轻人中自恋的比率正在增加。这与我们，
we talked about just a little while ago when you're talking about the pressures on young people? because they have so much outward pressure, is it making people more narcissistic? Is that the right way to describe what you're seeing? Yeah, I see that rising narcissisms, um, similar as the declining empathy because people who are narcissistic are, you know, more focused on themselves and less focused on others.
刚才谈到的关于年轻人面临的压力有关吗？因为他们有太多的外部压力，这是否使人们变得更自恋？这是描述你所看到的情况的正确方式吗？是的，我看到自恋的上升，类似于同理心的下降，因为自恋的人，你知道，更关注自己，而较少关注他人。
So it's negatively correlated with empathy. And those two trends were happening around the same time. And again, we're still working on the update for the narcissism paper as well. Um, but yes, I think that just generally all those pressures on young people can make them kind of shrink their scope of self rather than expanding it to include a lot of other people and concerns.
所以它与同理心呈负相关。这两个趋势大约在同一时间发生。同样，我们仍在努力更新自恋论文。但是，是的，我认为总的来说，年轻人身上所有的那些压力可能会使他们缩小自我的范围，而不是将其扩大到包括许多其他人及其关切。
It's just about more like survival in making it. And I think, you know, I don't have any causal evidence of this, but this is what I think is happening. Yeah, that's really, I mean, you think, you know, was it because of social media? and that's my next thing I want to touch on is some of your research you did and you presented this at the APA's convention in San Francisco in 2018. And your study you presented found that compassionate people spend less time on social media than people who are more self-centered and narcissistic.
这更多是关于生存和成功。我认为，你知道，我没有任何因果证据，但这确实是我认为正在发生的事情。是的，这真的，我的意思是，你认为，你知道，这是因为社交媒体吗？这是我想谈的下一个话题，即你所做的一些研究，你在2018年旧金山的美国心理学会大会上发表了这些研究。你发表的研究发现，富有同情心的人在社交媒体上花费的时间比那些更以自我为中心和自恋的人要少。
And you also found that people with lower emotional intelligence or those who have difficulty identifying, describing, and processing their emotions, they use social media more often than those who are more in touch with their feelings. Can you talk a little bit about that and how these traits interact with in the digital age and with social media? Yes. And there's a lot of research, including our own, that finds a correlation between narcissism and social media usage. But I don't necessarily think that means that social media use causes increased narcissism. And the studies that have tracked people over time find, if anything, it's the other way around.
你还发现，情商较低的人，或者那些在识别、描述和处理情绪方面有困难的人，比那些更了解自己感受的人更频繁地使用社交媒体。你能谈谈这一点，以及这些特质在数字时代和社交媒体中是如何相互作用的吗？是的。有很多研究，包括我们自己的研究，都发现自恋与社交媒体使用之间存在相关性。但我并不一定认为这意味着社交媒体的使用导致了自恋的增加。那些长期追踪人们的研究发现，如果有的话，情况恰恰相反。
that narcissistic people are just attracted to use social media because it really fits kind of, it can be used to fit their aims, which is to get a lot of attention. But I did find that I did present that work. It's still unpublished, but finding that empathy is correlated with less social media use. But since then, a mini meta-analysis came out with five different studies examining that link between empathy and social media. And interestingly, it actually found that there's a small positive correlation. So more empathetic people are using social media on average a little bit more. Could that be because, you know, social media can be a source for good and it can be an opportunity for people to do good things. I mean, I'm thinking about when people talk about their personal battles with depression and others chime in sharing their stories, their family stories, or people who share posts about a dog.
自恋的人只是被吸引去使用社交媒体，因为它真的很适合，它可以被用来满足他们的目的，那就是获得大量的关注。但我确实发现，我确实发表了那项工作。它仍然未发表，但发现同理心与较少的社交媒体使用相关。但从那以后，出现了一项小型荟萃分析，有五项不同的研究探讨了同理心与社交媒体之间的联系。有趣的是，它实际上发现存在微小的正相关。所以平均而言，更有同理心的人使用社交媒体稍微多一点。这可能是因为，你知道，社交媒体可以成为一种向善的源泉，它可以成为人们做好事的机会。我的意思是，我在想当人们谈论他们与抑郁症的个人斗争时，其他人加入进来分享他们的故事、他们的家庭故事，或者人们分享关于狗的帖子。
a high kill shelter and wanting to be adopted. So there's obviously a lot of good things going on social media. I think a lot of times, you know, you hear a lot about the negative aspects of it. So is that one of those examples you're talking about where you're seeing being more empathetic people using social media to connect with others to be forces for good out there? Yes, I think that people might, after looking at the research on this and understanding there's mixed effects both with narcissism and empathy in social media, I think the big picture takeaway that I have at this point is that people are online who they are offline. So empathetic people, when they're online, they're using the technology for different purposes and in different ways
一个高杀伤力的收容所，想要被领养。所以社交媒体上显然有很多好的事情发生。我想很多时候，你知道，你听到很多关于它的负面方面。那么，这是你所说的那些例子之一吗？你看到更有同理心的人利用社交媒体与他人联系，成为那里的向善力量？是的，我认为人们在查看了关于这个的研究并理解了社交媒体中自恋和同理心的混合影响后，我认为我目前最大的收获是，人们在线下是谁，在线上就是谁。所以有同理心的人，当他们在线时，他们使用技术是为了不同的目的和以不同的方式
than somebody who's narcissistic. That's really interesting. That's a good way to kind of put a fine point on it. Yeah. So it's like to connect. Right. So empathetic people are trying to, if they're using it a little more, it's because they're trying to connect with others. And there's many empathetic ways to engage. with people. Sometimes I think that not engaging can be empathetic, right? If there's somebody who's saying something really like that's really getting under your skin and making you angry and, you know, maybe the reaction would be that to just say something mean back, maybe inhibiting a mean response is an empathetic response nowadays. Yeah. And also, um, you're a lab from when I was reading. Um, you're using mobile phones. I'm thinking social media making that connection to
与自恋的人不同。这真的很有趣。这是一个很好的方式来点出重点。是的。所以就像是为了联系。对。所以有同理心的人正在尝试，如果他们使用它多一点，那是因为他们正在尝试与他人联系。并且有很多有同理心的方式来与人互动。有时我认为不互动也可以是同理心的，对吧？如果有人说了一些真的很让你心烦意乱并让你生气的话，你知道，也许反应会是回敬一些刻薄的话，也许抑制刻薄的反应在当今是一种有同理心的反应。是的。还有，嗯，你的实验室，当我阅读时。嗯，你正在使用手机。我在想社交媒体与
mobile phones. You were, you developed an app and you've done research about using mobile phones to implement empathy building programs. Can you talk a little bit more about that and what offerings you have in terms of using, harnessing this technology to build empathy in communities? Yeah. So that's exactly what we're trying to do because a lot of, I think a lot of the response to my declining empathy study was saying like, oh, well, empathy is declining because of social media because of smart phones. And I'm like, well, wait, let's look a little further back. I mean, it's been declining before then and face-to-face social connections were declining before then. So what's going on here? And we responded by saying, well, you know, we don't think that's the
手机的联系。你开发了一个应用程序，并且你已经做了关于使用手机来实施同理心培养程序的研究。你能多谈谈这一点，以及你在利用这种技术在社区中建立同理心方面有什么产品吗？是的。所以这正是我们试图做的，因为我认为对我的同理心下降研究的很多回应是说，哦，好吧，同理心正在下降是因为社交媒体，因为智能手机。我说，好吧，等等，让我们再往回看一点。我的意思是，在那之前它一直在下降，面对面的社交联系在那之前也在下降。所以这里发生了什么？我们回应说，好吧，你知道，我们不认为那是
cause necessarily, but this is something that young people really use a lot, you know, actually very attracted to using phones and social media. So why wouldn't we design programs that's kind of from their perspective, speak in their own language. So it's kind of an empathic design response, actually. And we designed two programs. One is called text to connect. And that's a daily text message reminders designed for obviously teenagers and older and young adults. So older young people. So it's just little reminders of to do things that I think everyone knows what to do, but just kind of like next to me you talk to a person, make sure you pay attention to their body language. and, you know, look them in the eye, like some really basic stuff.
必然的原因，但这确实是年轻人经常使用的东西，你知道，实际上非常喜欢使用手机和社交媒体。所以我们为什么不设计一些从他们的角度出发，用他们自己的语言说话的程序呢？所以这实际上是一种同理心设计的回应。我们设计了两个程序。一个是叫“发短信来联系”。那是为青少年及以上和年轻人设计的每日短信提醒。所以是更年长的年轻人。所以这只是提醒人们做一些我认为每个人都知道该怎么做的事情，但只是像在我旁边你和一个人交谈，确保你注意他们的肢体语言。
Or like next time you're talking to somebody, imagine what it feels like from their perspective. Like these are really obvious little reminders, but we did find, we have a published paper finding that this did help to increase empathy in college students. And we have unpublished data on teenagers for working on writing up, but also finding that it works. And so we also designed and tested a smartphone app designed for children age 10 to 17. And this one is called Random App of Kindness. And we had children come into our lab. And then they received either Random App of Kindness or a different app with for two months. And then we tested what happened to their empathy.
或者像下次你和某人交谈时，想象一下从他们的角度感受是什么样的。就像这些是非常明显的小提醒，但我们确实发现，我们有一篇已发表的论文发现这确实有助于提高大学生的同理心。我们有关于青少年的未发表数据，我们正在努力整理，但也发现它有效。所以我们也设计并测试了一个为10到17岁儿童设计的智能手机应用程序。这个叫“随机善意应用程序”。我们让孩子们来到我们的实验室。然后他们接受了“随机善意应用程序”或另一个应用程序，持续两个月。然后我们测试了他们的同理心发生了什么变化。
And we found, again, that this app can increase empathy in children. And within that age range, the younger kids preferred it. It was kind of cartoonish and they seemed to like that compared to the older kids. But we still found effects overall. Yeah, what you mentioned before about, I think that's really an interesting point that I've just been thinking about my own life, about how sometimes you just need to be reminded of these basic things. Like, we all know that we should be good to other people. You know, I think it's, you know, we all know, we know these things.
我们再次发现，这个应用程序可以增加儿童的同理心。在那个年龄段内，年龄较小的孩子更喜欢它。它有点卡通化，与年龄较大的孩子相比，他们似乎更喜欢那样。但我们仍然发现整体上有效果。是的，你之前提到的关于，我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，我一直在思考我自己的生活，关于有时你只需要被提醒这些基本的事情。就像，我们都知道我们应该对别人好。你知道，我认为这是，你知道，我们都知道，我们知道这些事情。
But I think sometimes bringing it to the forefront through these apps, whatever it's through, on a regular basis, if not daily basis, is really helpful in terms of living a better life and being better to people and to yourself. Yeah, that's what we were thinking. And part of it is if we see that there are gaps in our culture and what's surrounding ourselves and our children and these reminders, then why not use the thing that's with us at all times to remind us? I mean, phones are really a lot of potential to change our habits. Yeah. And just touching on your program that you run. It sounds pretty amazing. Interdisciplinary program on empathy and altruism. Is it unique in the field of psychology? And what other disciplines do you have as part of it? Well, we're just a lab group. So
但我认为有时通过这些应用程序，无论通过什么方式，定期，如果不是每天，将它带到最前沿，对于过上更好的生活以及对自己和他人更好是非常有帮助的。是的，这就是我们所想的。部分原因是如果我们看到我们的文化以及围绕我们自己和我们孩子的东西中存在差距，而这些提醒，那么为什么不使用一直伴随着我们的东西来提醒我们呢？我的意思是，手机确实有很多改变我们习惯的潜力。是的。并且谈谈你运行的程序。听起来很棒。关于同理心和利他主义的跨学科项目。它在心理学领域是独特的吗？你还有什么其他学科作为它的一部分？好吧，我们只是一个实验室小组。所以
most psychology researchers have a group of collaborators and other people they write with and do research with. So that's pretty much what we are. And it includes communication studies, philosophy. I'm just thinking about the different journals, marketing. I mean, just various you know, and it's been mostly quantitative at this point, but sociology. So just a bunch of different collaborators on the topics of interest related to empathy and altruism. And, you know, this is, this topic is not just a psychology topic. It's actually a topic that many people from various scholarly backgrounds are interested
大多数心理学研究人员都有一群合作者和其他他们一起写作和进行研究的人。所以这基本上就是我们。它包括传播学、哲学。我只是在想不同的期刊、市场营销。我的意思是，各种你知道，而且到目前为止它主要是定量的，但还有社会学。所以只是在与同理心和利他主义相关的感兴趣主题上的一群不同的合作者。而且，你知道，这个主题不仅仅是一个心理学主题。它实际上是一个许多来自不同学术背景的人都感兴趣的主题
in. And that's part of why I like working at the School of Philanthropy, because there are people from all different backgrounds, including humanities, and we're all studying questions related to giving and other pro-social behaviors. That's an excellent segue into our next section I want to get into about philanthropy. So the other area you study, you're in the school of philanthropy at Indiana University. And so during research for this topic, you know, I was reading about how much Americans donate every year. And before we started recording, you and I were talking about this a little bit more
，这也是我喜欢在慈善学院工作的部分原因，因为那里有来自各种不同背景的人，包括人文学科，我们都在研究与给予和其他亲社会行为相关的问题。这是一个很好的过渡，进入我们想谈的关于慈善的下一部分。所以你研究的另一个领域，你在印第安纳大学的慈善学院。所以在研究这个主题时，你知道，我读到了美国人每年捐赠多少钱。在我们开始录音之前，你和我正在谈论这个更多一点
and really parsing this information out. And when you look at the stats, they say that $427 billion was donated to charity last year. But as you told me, that number is in terms of like how that's divided up, that money is from mostly wealthy donors and not from individual donors. Can you talk a little bit more about that,
并真正解析这些信息。当你查看统计数据时，他们说去年向慈善机构捐赠了4270亿美元。但正如你告诉我的，那个数字在如何分配方面，这笔钱主要来自富有的捐赠者，而不是来自个人捐赠者。你能多谈谈这一点吗，
what these trends you're seeing in terms of wealthy donors giving larger chunks to that, to that $427 billion and individual. people giving less? Well, I mean, wealthy donors are individual donors, like say as compared to corporations, which are part of that number two. But when you just look at sort of the percentage of individuals who are giving, overall, there's, if you look at generational changes, my colleague Patrick Rooney at the School of Philanthropy wrote a paper on this recently and found that there are generational declines in the percentage of people who are giving to charity and then also how
你看到的这些趋势，关于富有的捐赠者向那4270亿美元捐赠了更大的份额，而个人捐赠者捐赠得更少？好吧，我的意思是，富有的捐赠者是个人捐赠者，比如与公司相比，公司也是那个数字的一部分。但当你只看捐赠的个人百分比时，总的来说，有，如果你看代际变化，我在慈善学院的同事帕特里克·鲁尼最近写了一篇关于这个的论文，发现捐赠给慈善机构的人数百分比存在代际下降，然后还有
much for giving on average. But the reason why we don't see that there are declines in the overall amount of giving is because there are larger donors who are giving more over time. So it makes it look like there isn't an overall decline in giving, but for a lot of the givers, there is a decline over time. And that means that nonprofits have to, you know, they're in a difficult position where they have to think about what the wealthy donors want and how to get, how to receive gifts from those people, or figure out how to get younger generations to be more involved in giving. How does the new tax law play into all that? Because in the past, you know, an individual donor would receive more of a tax benefit for giving. But for many Americans, I know, you know,
平均捐赠多少。但我们没有看到整体捐赠金额下降的原因是因为有更大的捐赠者随着时间的推移捐赠得更多。所以这看起来好像捐赠没有整体下降，但对于许多捐赠者来说，随着时间的推移确实有下降。这意味着非营利组织必须，你知道，他们处于一个困难的境地，他们必须考虑富有的捐赠者想要什么以及如何获得，如何从这些人那里获得礼物，或者弄清楚如何让年轻一代更多地参与捐赠。新的税法在所有这些中起什么作用？因为在过去，你知道，个人捐赠者会因为捐赠而获得更多的税收优惠。但对于许多美国人，我知道，你知道，
myself included, I found out last year the money I gave to chair. the clothes and whatever I donated, I got nothing back for. And so, you know, that is, that's a bummer. You know, you definitely want to feel like your contribution. You want to help others and be altruistic, but you also at the same time, it's, you know, why not get a tax break? So how do you think that might impact individual giving in the future? Again, my colleagues at the School of Philanthropy actually are studying this and are economists and they can, they can answer very much better than I can. but I can speak to work I've done on motivations for giving. I've designed a scale and personality scale that measures why people give clarity on average.
包括我自己，我去年发现我给慈善机构的钱。衣服和任何我捐赠的东西，我什么都没得到回报。所以，你知道，那是一个令人失望的事情。你知道，你肯定想感觉你的贡献。你想帮助别人并表现出利他主义，但你同时也，你知道，为什么不获得减税呢？所以你认为这可能会在未来如何影响个人捐赠？同样，我在慈善学院的同事实际上正在研究这个问题，他们是经济学家，他们可以，他们可以回答得比我好得多。但我可以谈谈我在给予动机方面所做的工作。我设计了一个量表和人格量表，衡量人们平均为什么给予清晰。
And actually, on average, people are not saying at least self-reporting that taxes are the most important motivation. They're actually saying that they give because they care as of altruism. But I still think that it would be, you know, obviously a major change in a tax law when you're, even if you're not giving. specifically because you want a tax break. If you're used of getting a tax break and then suddenly you don't, that might influence how you respond next year. Yeah, I mean, of course it's like, you know, I can only speak
实际上，平均而言，人们并没有说，至少是自我报告，税收是最重要的动机。他们实际上说他们给予是因为他们关心，这是利他主义。但我仍然认为，你知道，这显然是税法的一个重大变化，当你，即使你不是专门因为想要减税而给予。如果你习惯了获得减税，然后突然你没有了，那可能会影响你明年的反应。是的，我的意思是，当然就像，你知道，我只能从
from my own experience, but like I want to give to these causes, you know, but it's certainly nice, hey, I clear out the closet of some clothes, shoes, you know, gently use items and maybe get a little bit of money back. That was always a nice added bonus. And I was thinking last year as I was doing, earlier this year as I was doing taxes, like, wow, that is probably a little frightening for some, you know,
我自己的经验来说，但就像我想为这些事业捐赠，你知道，但肯定很好，嘿，我清理了衣柜里的一些衣服、鞋子，你知道，轻轻使用过的物品，也许能拿回一点钱。那总是一个很好的额外奖励。我在去年做的时候，今年早些时候做税收的时候在想，哇，这对一些人来说可能有点可怕，你知道，
profits if people aren't getting that tax break and might impact how much they give. So something to monitor. I think that is the case. And it's just that I'm not the one doing that research. There are people looking at that question. And also all of us have a constellation of motives. So it's not like the only thing we care about when giving to charity is all tourism. We all have sort of a mixed different, different reasons.
如果人们没有得到那个减税，可能会影响他们捐赠多少。所以需要监测。我认为确实如此。只是我不是做那项研究的人。有人在研究那个问题。而且我们所有人都有动机的组合。所以并不是说我们在向慈善机构捐赠时唯一关心的是利他主义。我们都有各种混合的、不同的原因。
Like some of it's about trusting charitable organizations or doing this is important when we love or because of taxes or because it makes. that's feel good. So taxes are in the mix. It came out as one of the motivations, you know, out of all the options we had. It's just that it's not necessarily the main one. You co-authored a recent study that found that people who volunteered had a lower mortality rate than those who gave money, which is really interesting. Why do you think that was the case? Well, first I want to just talk a little bit about what we did and then why we think we found the results. So we followed or we used a data set of very, from the Wisconsin Longitudinal Study that follows older adults.
比如有些是关于信任慈善组织或做这件事很重要，当我们爱或因为税收或因为它让人感觉良好。所以税收在其中。它作为我们拥有的所有选项中的动机之一出现。只是它不一定是主要的。你合著了一项最近的研究，发现做志愿者的人比那些捐钱的人死亡率更低，这真的很有趣。你认为为什么会这样？好吧，首先我想先谈谈我们做了什么，然后为什么我们认为我们发现了这些结果。所以我们追踪了，或者我们使用了一个来自威斯康星州纵向研究的数据集，该研究追踪了老年人。
They've been following people since 1957 when they graduated high school. And we compare different kinds of giving behaviors and also giving related traits, see how they were associated with the risk of dying several years later. And what we found was that giving time in various ways, whether it's volunteering or caregiving or helping friends, giving time is associated with a lower risk of mortality. But giving money was not, it was not associated with a lower risk of mortality.
他们从1957年高中毕业以来就一直在追踪人们。我们比较了不同种类的给予行为以及与给予相关的特质，看看它们与几年后死亡风险的关联。我们发现的是，以各种方式给予时间，无论是志愿服务还是照顾他人或帮助朋友，给予时间与较低的死亡风险相关。但给予金钱则不然，它与较低的死亡风险无关。
Also, people who thought that there were nine people, so for social traits was also associated with a lower risk of mortality. Just seeing yourself that way actually would seem to be associated with better health. Yeah, so why do you think giving to others, particularly giving time, as you mentioned, benefits mental and physical health? We think it has to do with, you know, how much people are giving of themselves. You can easily write a check and walk away without thinking about it. But it's hard to do that when you're volunteering.
此外，认为自己是九个人的人，所以对于社会特质也与较低的死亡风险相关。仅仅那样看待自己似乎就与更好的健康相关。是的，所以你认为为什么给予他人，特别是给予时间，正如你提到的，有益于心理和身体健康？我们认为这与，你知道，人们给予自己多少有关。你可以很容易地写一张支票然后走开而不去想它。但当你做志愿者时，很难做到这一点。
You're actually engaging, interacting with people. And there's, I think that there's a biological system that helps us to regulate stress. That when we are in a state where we're focusing on others and what they need and caring for others, the system helps to increase our oxytocin and rebuttal. reduce our cortisol. So a bonding hormone, the oxytocin, and then cortisol is a stress hormone. And doing that over and over again, whether because you just are naturally thinking of others and see yourself as prosocial, or whether because you're actually out there helping regularly, doing that can, I think, over time, be associated with better health. But I'm just guessing,
你实际上是在参与，与人互动。而且有，我认为有一个生物系统可以帮助我们调节压力。当我们处于一种专注于他人以及他们需要什么并关心他人的状态时，该系统有助于增加我们的催产素并减少我们的皮质醇。所以一种结合激素，催产素，然后皮质醇是一种压力激素。并且一遍又一遍地这样做，无论是仅仅因为你自然地想到他人并将自己视为亲社会，还是因为你实际上经常出去帮助，这样做，我认为，随着时间的推移，可能与更好的健康相关。但我只是在猜测，
based on our results, we don't quite have evidence yet. This is a really good conversation to be having at this time of year. I mean, this podcast will be running in December. Obviously, people can listen to it at any point, but at this time of year, people are giving a lot, whether they're giving time or money. And it's obviously a time where people are focusing on other people, you hope. So that would be a time to express empathy to others. So this is a very timely conversation. I want to thank you for taking the time to speak with me today. And I think our listeners will really take a lot away from this. And I'm really excited to see what happens with that research. You'll be publishing someday soon about what
基于我们的结果，我们还没有确凿的证据。这是一个在一年中的这个时候进行的好谈话。我的意思是，这个播客将在十二月播出。显然，人们可以在任何时候收听，但在一年中的这个时候，人们给予很多，无论是给予时间还是金钱。而且这显然是一个人们专注于他人的时间，你希望如此。所以这将是一个表达对他人的同理心的好时机。所以这是一个非常及时的谈话。我想感谢你今天抽出时间与我交谈。而且我认为我们的听众会从中获得很多。而且我真的很兴奋看到那项研究会发生什么。你将来有一天会发表关于
happened between 2009 and 2019 with rates of empathy. Yeah, I'm really curious too. And thank you so much for your amazing questions. It was a really interesting conversation. Well, I thank you. I really appreciate that. So before we go, I want to tell our listeners, we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. And also please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. It really helps. You can find all episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts, and also on our website, speakingofpsychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2009年到2019年之间同理心率发生了什么。是的，我也很好奇。非常感谢你提出的精彩问题。这是一个非常有趣的谈话。好吧，我谢谢你。我真的很感激。所以在我们走之前，我想告诉我们的听众，我们想听到你的声音。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在APA.org。也请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。这真的很有帮助。你可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到所有Speaking of Psychology的剧集，也可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。